اهلا بكم الى مجازين لاهم لمبه من قناه
الجزيره في قطر قال مراسل الجزيره ان
طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه شنت غارتين على
مواقع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وسط قطاع غزه
وجنوب مدينه غزه وقالت كتائب القسامه
الذراع العسكري لحركه حماس ان دفاعاتها
الجويه تتصدت للطائرات الاسرائيليه وقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف موقعين
لتخزين المواد الخام التي تستخدمها حماس
في انتاج الصواريخ
قال مبعوث ايران لدى الامم المتحده امير
سعيد ايراني ان التحقيقات الاوليه تشير
الى ان اسرائيل مسؤوله عن الهجوم على
منشاه عسكريه في اصفهان بطائره مسيره
واضاف اروانيا ان العمل الذي قامت به
اسرائيل يدينه القانون الدولي
ويتعارض معه
كشف المستشار في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل بولياك عن وجود محادثات بين
اوكرانيا
وكانها بشان تزويدها وشركائها بشان
تزويدها بصواريخ بعيده المدى وطائرات
هجوميه بينما قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ان المهمه الاساسيه امام بلاده هي
وقف وردع اي محاولات قصف من اوكرانيا
للاراضي الروسيه المتاخمه لها
في تونس استنكر اتحاد الشغل توقيف احد
نقابييه ودعا الى التعبئه للدفاع عن
الحريات العامه والحق في الاضراب من جانبه
اتهم القيادي في جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه رضا
بالحاج في تصريح الجزيره الرئيس قيس سعيد
بالخلط بين مهامه كرئيس وبينما سماه ميوله
السياسي وروحه الانتقاميه ازاء معارضيه
قال نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه
الى انخفاض نسبه المشاركه في الانتخابات
التونسيه مؤشر على ضروره انخراط الحكومه
في عمليه شامله لتوسيع المشاركه السياسيه
ابرمت الولايات المتحده والفلبين اتفاقا
يسمح للجنود الامريكيين استخدام اربع
قواعد عسكريه اضافيه بموجب اتفاقيه
التعاون الدفاعي لعام 2014 بين البلدين
جاء الاتفاق مع بدايه زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي اليوم الى مانيلا حيث اجرى
محادثات مع الرئيس الفلبيني بشان فتح مزيد
من القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه
رفضت الولايات المتحده وصف كوريا الشماليه
للتدريبات العسكريه المشتركه التي جرت
بشبه الجزيره الكوريه بانها استفزاز
وقلم متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي انه لا ليت عدائيه لواشنطن تجاه
وان الولايات المتحده تسعى بالدبلوماسيه
الجاده الى معالجه جميع القضايا التي تهم
المنطقه
انتهى المجاز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]